Hi, I'm Natasha.
Today at the Ri we're going to be
doing something we've been
wanting to do for a really long time.
But it is incredibly dangerous so we had to
make sure we knew how to do it safely
before we made this video.
And in case you were wondering,
do not try this at home.
Ready...? Burn!
So we're going to attempt to make
something called Lichtenberg figures.
These are beautiful branching
patterns that you can burn into wood
using electricity.
The reason why they're so dangerous
is because if you don't know what you're doing,
the voltages and the currents can kill you.
So no pressure!
I took apart an old microwave to get the
transformer, again don't try this at home,
the magnetron in the microwave contains
beryllium oxide powder,
which is highly toxic, and also the residual charge in the capacitor could always kill you
if you don't discharge it properly.
This is something that can step up the mains voltage to over 2,000 volts,
this will then travel along these wires here to these electrodes
and this is where the magic happens.
So let's see if this works...
I'm going to wet the wood with some salt
solution, the ions help conduct the
electricity a little bit better.
Okay so I'm plugging it in, it's potentially live...
System is live... and burn!
That worked really well actually!
And second time... Burn!
So what's happening here?
We expect wood to be an insulator,
but we've wetted the surface with a salt
solution which can conduct electricity,
which completes the circuit between the
two bolts.
This means that current can flow,
and the current heats up the water,
causing it to evaporate.
The electric field is highest
around the points of the bolts
so this bit heats up first.
It gets so hot that the wood starts to burn.
This burning wood produces a kind of
carbon that can conduct electricity,
a little bit like graphite.
This burnt carbon creates a pathway
where current can flow,
which means you get even more
resistive heating and even more burning.
So the tendrils are an advancing conductive front,
burning a path for themselves as they go.
This is what makes the beautiful
branching Lichtenberg patterns.
Once these two fronts meet,
you have a line of burnt wood
which is quite good at conducting electricity.
So suddenly you get a lot of current, and
you see that lovely flash.
Interestingly since we've been
using plywood for this demonstration,
some of the pathways have gone between the plies
and then popped up here and here
as tendrils on the surface.
So that's it for this video.
I really enjoyed building this
demonstration from scratch
and seeing the beautiful patterns
being burnt into the wood.
So if you liked the video, don't
forget to subscribe,
you can also support the Ri on Patreon.